[Music]
the king and this thing and the Bing and
the wing and the string and the ding and
I I I don't remember the whole [ __ ]
name anymore to be honest with you
um and uh he and then obviously theovan
predictively you know because he said he
needed to take a step back and focus on
stuff so he obviously stopped doing all
his other shows and all those other
stuff too right
a little take a little no he's doing
right here oh I wanted to ask him so
what happened in the yeah this uh
[ __ ] uh no gas no dignity now guy on
no gas no dignity yeah yeah yeah that's
his new thing he used to be cool and now
he's just [ __ ] mini Tim Hyde actors
of his former self it's sad right on the
sting podcast it's no longer oh the king
and the sting podcast yeah the the the
the podcast is still going I'm just not
I'm not doing it you're Brandon cool
though yeah yeah
now I'm not one of those people that
like a professional at recreating body
language or anything it doesn't look
like they're cool but it doesn't look
like they're cool
yeah
I'm
cool
yeah we just honestly man I missed I
couldn't I didn't have enough attention
really to focus yeah like I like I like
my own podcast and we have a unique kind
of audience I think yeah and I think I
wanted to be able to I feel a lot more
in touch with this now
he is a [ __ ] politician man
and I like Theo and before people
started screaming what is in the app
because Theo seems like the kind of guy
that doesn't want to find anybody am I
wrong about that like he just seems like
like nah man I just won't do it anymore
that's cool also Theo probably doesn't
have a lot of animosity he's probably
just like I still want to be around him
anymore but I'm not going to start
burying the guy to put this pile on
because you guys hate him and want
everybody to pile on him right
yeah like it's important to me yeah and
it was still important but it was just a
lot to try and juggle yeah okay so I
okay let me skip this guy here
I'm sorry I have to skip over you sir
but I was very low on prep and I had to
grab the wrong video so here we are
that's kind of what every guy thinks
though yeah you know you gotta uh I
don't mean everybody thinks you have a
soft jaw I mean every guy thinks that
they have a soft jaw
would you just see me it's a new set
yeah all right we're working
this is the new king and the sting and
the Bing and the wing set
this looks way worse than the last set
right the last set had like the logo
behind them you don't like the cheap uh
thing that looks like they're in a
inside of the Westworld logo they look
like they're inside of every cup that I
drink out of in the 80s it had like the
design you know what I'm talking about
yeah
holy [ __ ] they look like they're in the
smaller room in the laser tag place
where you get your backpack in the
[ __ ] gun did you do your show inside
an LA Gear shoe like I'm trying to
understand what this is about why is
this show being done in an Apple Store
yeah why are the two Tron Cycles racing
behind you what's happening here through
the wrinkles all right some things pop
off I don't want to get too big that was
weird
this morning
you know what happens I look like a goat
yeah there's a ghost in here you know
who that is
it's pretty funny
that made Brandon uncomfortable look at
him
[Laughter]
we gotta talk about Finance
we gotta talk about Finance dude and
they're doing the theory it was this a
money thing I don't know but but this is
something this is one of those things
when you know everybody has like an
inside joke
that they probably were talking some
[ __ ] before the show started kind of
like we do with our AG guy and then we
they take these little shots but I mean
every guy thinks that they I gotta see
something sorry I have to
see me it's a new set yeah all right
we're working through the wrinkles all
right some things pop up I don't want to
get too big that was weird
this morning yeah
you know what happens I look like a
ghost yeah there's a ghost in here you
know who that is
so this part this part this part coming
up
uh we gotta talk about Finance
was it a money thing
maybe I don't know
I don't know man it looked uncomfortable
I may not make it
I liked uh the Gringo poppy actually
this guy
this guy is
just I think he's it feels like when you
know when someone's just trying to be
counter for no reason
you know what I mean by the way I'll say
this right now R.I.P to the original
excuse me what was 10 times better than
all gas no breaks 100 yeah absolutely
yeah yeah oh I think people give Brennan
so much
uh Flack and I think that's one of the
reasons I admire him in some ways yeah
is how you could withstand so much
uh disdain from people you know or fake
this thing yeah
it's an awful fake Theo some of us feel
feel it's not all Facebook
um maybe you could accuse us of that
until he [ __ ] had been pixels take
our [ __ ] down then maybe
but it's not fake anymore okay pretty
psychotic
crazy isn't it yeah it goes back to the
people you were talking about now this
is where things get very interesting
are you sure can I just get interesting
and of course you're probably the first
guy in your family
's Gonna Come
of course the fear is going to come up
and of course yeah
I don't know what this is gonna come up
so I always just tell my students say
what do you feel like right now smile
into that feeling
[Music]
[Applause]
really staying grounded in your body and
your feet good and then you reach for is
this guy covering that you basically cut
the toes appreciate a step back from
being on uh this is the original yeah
and uh
I just want to thank you guys for
um just being a part of my life and and
letting this show be a part of your life
and uh but again like and I agree with
like what Marsha saying earlier like
this speech would make sense if you were
like gonna stop podcasting like all
together because let's be honest it's
probably the same fan base here right
we're assuming that I'm assuming the
king and the sting fan base are the same
as the Theo Von fan base it's it's got
to be the same in the same way nightwave
and day wave and RDC have the fun of the
same fan base you know yeah I mean
there's probably a little bit of a
deviation but the overall overall like
it's it just seems weird and and if it
is a maybe it is a finance thing I
honestly have no [ __ ] clue
but
all I'm saying is that little back and
forth was a little dicey dicey pop off
you know what I mean